sabemos que la derivada con respecto a x
de la x es igual a la equis y eso es
algo realmente sorprendente del número e
pero bueno no estamos aquí ahora para
maravillar nos del número e lo que
realmente quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar la derivada de la función
inversa del número e es encontrar la
derivada con respecto a x del logaritmo
natural de x y ya hemos hecho esto
anteriormente conocemos la derivada de
una función y encontramos la derivada de
su función inversa que hacemos
supongamos que es igual a logaritmo
natural de x esta es otra manera de
decir que ya es la potencia la cual
tenemos que elevar y para obtener x es
decir que he elevado a la potencia y es
igual a x ahora podemos tomar la
derivada a ambos lados de esta ecuación
con respecto a x hagamos eso derivamos
con respecto a x ambos lados aquí vamos
a tener que hacer algo de derivación
implícita que en realidad es aplicar
regla de la cadena y ahora del lado
izquierdo que tenemos la derivada con
respecto a x de alaye es el ayer
que multiplica a la derivada con
respecto a x de iu y esto es igual a la
derivada con respecto a x dx que es
igual a 1 despejamos de jane de x
dividimos a ambos lados entre el aire de
jane dx de jane dx es igual a 1 sobre
y elevado a la potencia y deja de
ponerlo así mejor he elevado a la
potencia y ahora ya a que es igual aquí
vemos que es igual a logaritmo natural
de x así es que esto es igual esto es
igual a 1 sobre y elevado a la potencia
logaritmo natural de x que ya vimos que
es lo mismo que y ya cuánto es igual a
la potencia logaritmo natural de x bueno
si logaritmo natural de x es el número
al que tengo que elevar y para obtener x
elevado al logaritmo natural de x es
simplemente x así es que esto es igual
esto es igual a 1 sobre 1 sobre x 1
sobre x esto de aquí es simplemente
equis y ya hemos concluido hemos
calculado que si es igual a logaritmo
natural de x la derivada de ye con
respecto a x es igual a 1 entre x o
directamente la derivada con respecto a
x del logaritmo natural de x es igual a
1 entre x
si es que esto de aquí esto de aquí es
igual esto de aquí es igual
1 / x que también es un resultado
sorprendente en matemáticas no tan
sorprendente como este resultado de acá
pero también tiene lo suyo